so this is the one that's going to get
me in trouble cuz it's easy to tell
somebody hey you got to be healthy hey
you got to deal with past hurts you got
to deal with your relationship
challenges and and loneliness but we've
entered a space in our culture where
it's not cool to say hey if you want to
live a non-anxious life if you want
peace you have to choose belief you have
to choose to believe in something bigger
than
yourself
this idea of I don't believe in
anything that's a modern privilege all
of human history until just a couple
hundred years ago people walked out of
their tent they walked out of their Hut
they walked out of their cave and they
looked to the sky and they said dear God
or dear Gods please rain or my kids will
die there's an innate submission to a
higher power something that operates the
cosmos
and then we got real smart we started
solving some of these issues that have
plagued Humanity for all of human
history lack of food winter how do we
eat ah now I got a cell phone I just
push a button and food shows up at my
house clean water just turn that nozzle
and we started
deconstructing us the way we think about
things and feel about things and we
created this idea that the goal of human
existence distance is
self-actualization if you get safety and
you get security and you get food and
you get relationships the world will
then revolve around you and here we are
you and me we have everything and we're
spinning out of control because this
self was never designed to be actualized
the self was never designed to hold up
the burdens of the universe and now we
worship the thing that we think will
save us we worship our political party
we worship our physical health we
worship our money as the great David
Foster Wallace says we are beings
created to worship and Foster Wallace
was an atheist this wasn't a religious
statement this was a fact and what we're
all finding out you and me and all of us
in real
time they don't hold they're not going
to save us
building a non-anxious
life is about surrender about taking a
knee and saying I can't hold up the
universe there's a higher power than me
in
action choosing belief comes in two
important parts letting go and anchoring
into the
source for all of human history God's
decided what you wore what your roles
were who did what and why yes there was
oppression yes people got squashed but
the point was there was a unifying story
and in the last few years we've clipped
all the unifying stories we've
untethered oursel from the source and
when you let go and you're not anchored
in you become a balloon or a feather
lost in the Wind on the other side if
you anchor in and you don't let go you
become a source of political division
and tension trying to die on every Hill
it's a way of pretending that you're not
holding up the universe but you're still
trying to hold it with all your might so
you have to Anchor in you have to
believe in something bigger than
yourself and for my science friends it's
got to be bigger than the scientific
method we've worshiped that for the last
few hundred years and for my deeply
religious passionately religious friends
it has to be deeper than your sets of
rules we're talking about the source
we're talking about God we're talking
about the love that moves through the
universe and holds all things together
and as a science nerd I don't want that
to be the case as somebody who spent my
whole life trying to use my intellect to
solve why I had such a gaping hole
inside of me I don't want it to be the
case I want to have all the answers and
I want to have it figured out I just
know this to be true you have to Anchor
in to something bigger than yourself to
a higher power and you have to let
go so about a year ago I got an email
from my boss my boss said hey I got us
all
tickets to go skydiving who's in and
quickly the reply alls came through I'm
out I'm out I'm out and as a matter of
spite I immediately responded I'm in
send accept
I'm so scared of heights I don't like
going up secondstory staircases when my
son gets up on a chair to change a light
bulb my heart stops I hate heights but I
said I was in and the whole flight up in
this old tankered plane with duct tape
on the inside of the plane it was duct
tape together and then came the Fateful
moment when they slam the door open I
held on to the former special forces guy
that was Tethered to me
and before I could
answer he
jumped and in that moment we were freef
falling I let
go and I open my arms up enjoying the
ride Tethered to somebody who's going to
keep me
safe that's
belief back 10 years ago when I wasn't
well I spent a year with with a man who
was both a bioethics professor and a
part-time monk he said John so often
sarcasm and pessimism present his wisdom
and joy and optimism and peace present
his foolishness as nonsense we have an O
really
culture and it's much easier to knock
their building down than it is to build
our own and so we live and breathe
sarcasm G pessimism you know it's all
coming down you know it's not true and
we pretend that joy and
optimism and peace and belief are
stories for children are myths of the
old age and I'll ask us just to look
around what has our sarcasm and
pessimism got us the most anxious
generation in human
[Music]
history I know the idea of choosing
belief is heavy there's religious trauma
that you may have gone through there are
religious systems that have burdened you
and beat you down there are scientists
and mentors and thinkers who have
laughed and scoffed at the idea of a
higher power it's just silly it's for
children but one thing I know to be
certain if you make you the center of
the world you will collapse under the
wait choose to set down sarcasm and
pessimism choose to set down intellect
solving everything choose to rest in a
higher power choose to say I
surrender I can't hold it up any longer
it's not an excuse to stop living your
life and it's not an excuse to cash out
and it's not an excuse to not go be
ambitious and try to solve some of the
world's most vexing problems we need you
I need you but I'm I'm asking you to do
it anchored
in anchored into a higher power anchored
into God and this is belief and this is
the path to a non-anxious
[Music]
life